bonjour
[Musique]
elle symbolise le 21e siècle digital et
les traditions ancestrales
la corée du sud et ses 51 millions
d'habitants dont la moitié habite la
capitale séoul le pays le plus connecté
au monde avec internet donc 90% des
foyers
c'est une nation plein essor économique
et culturel que viennent conquérir les
châteaux du val de loire
ça n'arrête pas zack rendez-vous cinq
rendez-vous par jour dans une grande
ville comme c hall avec autant de trafic
c'est assez rare c'est assez ambitieux
cette fois ci l'entrevue a lieu au
restaurant nous célébrons le 500e
anniversaire de la mort de léonard de
vinci
donc c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
vous avez toutes ces visites de
différents châteaux gaël représente le
clos lucé et marque le château d'amboise
deux lieux intimement liée à la vie du
génie italien pour les corps est un
moyen simple un moyen mnémotechnique
pour
comprendre le siècle dont on parle on
l'a on vous parle du temps du 16e siècle
est le moyen le plus simple c'est de
penser à prendre un billet de 1000 one
de sully à wang yong et le personnage
contemporain de léonard encore & young
est astronome
il est également mathématicien et
philosophe tout comme l'était leona les
célébrations de la renaissance
un thème qui arrive à point nommé pour
les tour-opérateurs coréenne c'est le
bon moment pour nous de voyager parce
qu'il ya encore cinq ans
notre priorité c'était gagner de
l'argent c'est ce qui comptait le plus
mais maintenant la tendance est au
changement
on cherche plutôt à se cultiver
connaître l'histoire et à s'ouvrir sur
l'extérieur
donc c'est vraiment la bonne période
pour découvrir ce que les châteaux de la
loire
honte à nous proposer
depuis 20 ans date à laquelle les
coréens ont obtenu des passeports pour
sortir de leur pays
la société a radicalement changé
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié de la
population voyages à l'étranger 145000
coréens viennent chaque année en france
la destination la plus visitée en europe
devant l'italie l'espagne et la croatie
si paris reste incontournable apparaît
une envie nouvelle de découvrir les
régions
une opportunité que tente de saisir
pierre-alain roiron le président du
comité régional du tourisme est reçu par
l'ambassadeur de france pour promouvoir
là encore le label loire valley les kora
sont férus de technologie c'est un peu
de technologie et quoi de plus beau que
l'histoire de départ de vinci pour
montrer à la fois la technologie sous
ses aspects purement techniques mais
également pour ses implications en terme
de révolution culturelle
léonard de vinci c'est un ingénieur de
la technologie d'il ya cinq cents ans
est donc aujourd'hui encore et c'est
très important la nouvelle technologie
92% des coréennes et coréens ou un
smartphone et ils regardent des
informations donc il est important que
l'on puisse être présent ici
et puis c'est un marché qui globalement
pour la france et 10 à 15% de plus de
visiteurs chaque année nous retrouvons
les représentants des châteaux de la
loire
en plus du clos lucé et d'amboise il y à
chenonceau blois chaumont et leurs
rivaux pour un rendez-vous groupé chez
un des plus gros tours opérateurs corée
en europe and actuelle et par des femmes
dont deux reines de france catherine de
médicis donc si vous avez beaucoup de
temps vous pouvez passer du temps au
château est aussi en ville si vous avez
moins de temps en une heure une heure
une heure et demie on peut visiter le
château est ensuite allé h he et la vie
de château ne manque pas d'attrait pour
les coréens
on a absolument tout pour les faire
venir parce que là nous étions dans une
agence qui était un peu spécialisé dans
les produits de luxe pour les petits
groupes et eux ça les intéresse
directement de pouvoir voir l'histoire
autrement et dans un cadre tout à fait
particulier dans une thématique
particulière en effet d'un côté
privilégié vivre leur las de passer pour
attirer les touristes
il est important de comprendre leur
culture si les jeunes corée entre 18 et
20 ans sont à 100% équipe est un
smartphone un record mondial
il n'hésite pas à revêtir le costume
traditionnel pour aller faire des selphy
dans le quartier d anouk ces maisons de
bois traditionnels corinne foulquier la
responsable d'atout france à séoul a
pour mission de promouvoir les richesses
touristiques de l'hexagone en corée du
sud
elle décrypte le comportement des
coréens pour la délégation régionale qui
s'inquiètent de l'impact de la crise des
gilet jaune
ils sont très sensibles aux notions
sécuritaire mais vous pourrez le
constater ici à séoul ils manifestent
mais manifestent sans violence
ça le droit à manifester c'est quelque
chose de très important donc ils sont
pas effrayés par les manifestations en
revanche l'aspect sécuritaire c'est très
important parce que la sécurité ici
quand on manifeste ça se passe sans
violence la présidente a été destitué
l'a pris 25 ans de prison
et ça s'est passé sans casser un pot de
fleurs sans une arrestation sans brûler
une voiture depuis plus de dix ans le
niveau de vie en corée crois bien plus
vite qu'en europe et le pays est
aujourd'hui la 12e puissance économique
mondiale un marché touristique d'avenir
pour le val de loire 2019 ce n'est pas
une fin en soi c'est un commencement
pour faire mieux connaître notre région
à l'étranger et je crois que c'est
quelque chose d'important
le fait même que nous exerçons nous
soyons passés du nom région centre à
centre val de loire
ça veut dire quelque chose donc c'est un
atout qu'il faut pouvoir mettre en avant
de façon importante nous sommes dans une
région où il ya des nouvelles
technologies où il y adeux larchitecture
de l'art contemporain de la culture il
faut continuer à la mettre en avant
tussauds
on
[Musique]
le temps
oui
c'est une soirée exceptionnelle au
dernier étage du plaza de séoul
j'étais en cas de sinistre chaque
visiteur à une tablette histo pas et
dans chaque pièce
vous avez une borne sur le sol vous
allez l'as canet et la tablette va vous
emmener dans cette même pièce mais 500
ans en arrière donc maintenant nous
sommes en 15/100 1 et nous sommes dans
les cuisines du roi c'est très
intéressant de se retrouver plongé à
cette époque c'est plus facile à
comprendre
une soixantaine de journalistes bloggers
et influenceurs coréens sont invités
pour cette présentation des 500 ans de
la renaissance le voyage en france est
un marqueur social
donc la france attire les coréens la
région centre val de loire et juste à
une heure où varient évidemment je parle
un peu le tour soit chartrand ter soit
ou en tgv
mais quand vous êtes juste à une heure
de paris après vous avez la culture ce
qui le top numéro un pour les coréens
après vous avez la nature la région
centre à val de loire et quand même
classé au patrimoine mondial unesco pour
ses paysages
après vous avez la gastronomie le vin le
lot tourisme
enfin je veux dire il ya tous les atouts
qui sont là maintenant après il faut
déjà faire un audit ce qui est
disponible en région centre
une fois que le dit effrayé qu'est ce
qui est possible de faire ce qu'il est
possible de proposer comme produit et
l'offre après il faut la mettre en
marché quoi tout simplement décor est un
féru de culture mais qui ne font pas
forcément le rapport entre le val de
loire et léonard de vinci
j'ai visité la région il ya quatre ans
et j'ai vu tous ces beaux châteaux mais
je ne connaissais pas le lien entre
léonard de vinci et la région et je ne
savais pas qu'il était mort en touraine
je comprend mieux l'importance de tous
ces événements dans le val de loire les
manifestations autour des cinq sens en
sont le thème retenu au niveau national
en 2019 pour vendre la destination
france à l'étranger et la tournée
léonard de vinci dans 11 pays du monde
est un investissement de taille pour le
val de loire
un investissement que les élus justifie
par l'impact économique aujourd'hui dans
le pib français
là la part du tourisme c'est un peu plus
que la part de la production automobile
cc % pour la production automobile 7%
pour l'activité touristique donc c'est
une activité qui créent de l'emploi qui
crée de la richesse et qui est aussi une
activité d'aménagement du territoire
quand j'ai une région comme la nôtre
[Applaudissements]
wu
jeunesse à tunis
[Musique]
le marathon des rendez-vous s'achève à
séoul avec un gros morceau
lagence kuoni acteur incontournable du
tourisme en asie ici les échanges se
font en anglais devant un parterre de
très jeunes salariés
des châteaux à schwerin ce château est
très important pour l'histoire de france
c'est 3 et 10 rennes ont vécu ici
c'était la résidence favorite des rois
au xvième siècle honda 600 chevaux
les châteaux blois chaumont sur loire et
leurs rivaux ont un temps limité pour
présenter leurs atouts respectifs
sans entrer en concurrence c'est pas du
tout l'esprit au contraire on essaie de
faire quelque chose de complémentaire
parce que l'objectif c'est de faire
venir ces gens là dans notre région donc
il est hors de question qu'on joue perso
on est vraiment là pour donner une
complémentarité des sites qui de toute
façon est naturellement qui existe
naturellement donc au contraire on est
là pour essayer de les faire venir en
leur montrant les complémentarités
au terme d'un séjour coréen où la
délégation a enchaîné plusieurs dizaines
de rendez vous l'heure est plutôt à
l'optimisme
[Musique]
c'est un pays qui en 30 ans a
complètement changé et ils sont capables
de faire la même chose pour tous donc
c'est vraiment incroyable
les offres enfin j'ai l'impression que
ce second on leur a parlé ils sont
capables de mettre en place les
changements tout de suite contrairement
aux japonais qui met trois ans les
chinois qui tergiverse ci et qui vont
négocier tous les prix c'est pas du tout
les mêmes cultures
si les festivités des 500 ans font la
part belle à l'architecturé du 16e
siècle le présent n'est pas oubliée pas
justement une façon quelque part à
partir de 2019 de lancer d'un sucre est
en fait une nouvelle énergie pour aller
vers des renaissances qu'elle soit
culturelle artistique technologique
c'est important ce n'est pas disneyland
on va garder notre possible nos
spécificités notre histoire notre
patrimoine mais on a des nouveaux outils
de médiation maintenant pour faire
découvrir ce patrimoine le faire aimer
aussi
faire du val de loire une marque
emblématique de l'esprit renaissance
dans le monde entier et de léonard de
vinci
un ambassadeur universelle est un pari
politique et économique ambitieux une
occasion à ne pas manquer pour une
région qui veut renforcer son identité
[Musique]